bei herzlich willkommen hallo wie geht's
euch geht's euch gut das ist schön ich
werde heute bürger machen dann im
anschluss gibt es ein kleines mit bahn
und live update ich mein leben ist jetzt
nicht so interessant aber vielleicht
gibt es da den ein oder anderen der was
hören möchte und dafür ist das doch
dieser teil des videos entsteht in
kooperation mit kaufland in kaufland
möchte auf etwas aufmerksam auf die
etwas andere die etwas anderen sind
gemüse und obstsorten die nachlässig
werden ungeliebte kinder sozusagen und
ganz ehrlich so sind wendig wir lieben
jeden egal welche form oder farbe sie
haben wir schon auf die inneren wert und
deswegen gibt's bei kaufland obst und
gemüseabteilungen in denen man verformte
zu kleine zu große rummel schiefe
gemüsesorten wie zb karotten kartoffeln
oder äpfel finden kann zusätzlich haben
wir das problem dass viele lebensmittel
die produziert werden am ende in der
tonne land das finde ich extrem schade
natürlich einkaufen dann zu mir kann man
gesagt hat helfer wir haben hier ecken
wo lebensmittel kurz vorm
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum stehen euch
jetzt mal total verwundert dass
irgendwie noch nie so wahrgenommen und
als ich dann zu kaufland gegangen wenn
du mir das angeschaut habe hatte ich das
wieder gut deswegen werde ich heute
bürger machen mit zutaten die kurzform
ablauf sind wie wir wissen ist das
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum mir kein datum
wo man sagt hier ab diesem tag ist
vorbei
da kannst du das nicht mehr essen wir
haben ja immer noch unsere sinne und wir
können ja ein brot fühlen können riechen
sie können schauen
gibt es denn schon
welchen schimmel drauf nein sieht
fantastisch aus und das fest ist wenn
man darauf achtet kann man sogar noch
geld dabei sparen und das finde ich
klasse dass mich unterstützen und
deswegen kochen wir heute mit zutaten
die fast abgelaufen sind fünf tipps um
lebensmittel zu hause vor der tonne zu
retten überlege dir was du in nächster
zeit kochen wirst und kaufe nur die
lebensmittel ein die du auch wirklich
brauchst produkte die das
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum zuhause
überschritten haben erst gründlich
prüfen bevor man sie wegwirft gebe obst
und gemüse eine zweite chance und
schneide die schlechten stellen ab bevor
sie komplett in der tonne landen über
apps und social media gruppen findest du
dankbare abnehmer für deine lebensmittel
die du nicht mehr verbrauchen kannst
reflektiere deinen verbrauch und schaue
was du in zukunft noch besser machen
kannst ich würde sagen ich beginne mal
mit einem kleinen hall video was habe
ich so gefunden was habe ich eingekauft
brot für 50 prozent günstiger habe
nichts von den etwas anderen mitgenommen
weil wir tatsächlich kartoffeln und
äpfel noch zu hause hatten und ich
wollte jetzt nicht extra fürs video nun
zu zeigen
kaufen und dann am ende schmeiße ich das
weg und der sinn ist irgendwie so
überhaupt nicht mehr da eine zitrone
limettenschale die möchte ich sofort
probieren
ich hab noch ein zweites micro hier
stehen wenn ihr meine story übernachten
wisst ihr dass deswegen für meine nase
mehr freund ist das jetzt ein kleines
fantastico und nur 14 cent toll kommen
jetzt aber zu unserem burger dafür
fangen wir an mit der grillsaucen und da
muss man ja wirklich sagen soße ist für
immer haltbar
also wie lange wir saucen benutzten
haben in excel soße für 39
ich sehe da habe ich mich sehr gefreut
sind bis zum 15 12 uhr lag dann passend
zu halloween sind einfach schwarze
burger brötchen
die habe ich zum beispiel im
kassenbereich gefunden da wo die ganzen
reduzierten nicht gekühlten waren stehen
dann gibt es noch einen camembert von
demeter 30 prozent günstiger und heute
ist das ablaufdatum dann habe ich
natürlich vegane burger pettys geholt es
gibt auch tatsächlich sehr viel fleisch
in diesen kühl abteilungen und da sollte
man wirklich immer mal hinschauen und
sich bei der gemüse und obst abteilung
mitgenommen hatte ist dieser leicht
anging gammelte salat aber da hat man
einfach nur die äußeren blätter art und
drinnen ist er noch frisch und gut der
hätte ein eur 46 gekostet und ich haben
uns gezeigt
da kriegt der ostblock rein dann mache
ich werde jetzt die pace anbraten
die burger brötchen ein bisschen
knusprig machen käse drauf salatblätter
drauf und dann sehen wir uns beim oberen
teil wieder disclaimer sehr geehrte
damen und herren nun beginnt der muk
bahn teil des videos das bedeutet ich
werde reden und essen lautet schwarz
geräusche sind dabei leider nicht
vermeidbar
also schalten sie jetzt weg falls sie
diese nicht aushalten können tara diesem
einem gruseligen burger
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass diese
zutaten in der tonne gelandet werden ich
nicht befürchte dass frau war einfach da
muss ich denke es probieren
android wie gut mittlerweile ersatz
fleisch schmeckt besonders burger pittis
wenn wir die sind richtig gut
wow ich habe ich noch jährlich aber noch
zu hause
ich habe gerade darüber nachgedacht wie
lange es schon her ist seit ich mein
letztes mietbaren video hochgeladen habe
und ich glaube dass wenn er schon zwei
jahren drei mal waren im bank in meiner
erinnerung habe ich somit bahn dreimal
gemacht 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13
videos
da habe ich damit aufgehört
die alten schwarzem sesam benutzen
können wenn man sie denn weißen sesam
benutzt schwarz update leute und falls
ihr so richtig bock hat in die kamera zu
schreiben da vanessa das ist voll eklig
mit dem schwarzen okay okay
wichtigste frage wo ist mir da
ich glaub und nun werde ich bin mir gar
nicht so sicher
am ende so süß es ist für mich nicht wie
geht es dir
gute frage wenn du mich jetzt auch der
straße gesehen würdest und fragen
würdest vanessa wie geht es dir dann
würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen ja alles
gut
sie muss aber ehrlicherweise weil ich im
internet ja die ehrlichste person bin
und im rila nicht es geht mir zurzeit
komisch weil ich aber auch so ein wandel
irgendwie durch mache also ich merke
dass mein charakter sich gerade wieder
so ein bisschen verändert formt
definiert hier noch weitere begriffe
einfügen
und das ist immer so eine zeit wo dann
wo man dann immer viel an sich selber
beobachtet
darin geht es mit teilweise nicht so
blendend
aber ich glaube auch das schlägt in
corona zu den leuten gehört die wirklich
sehr entspannt waren was heißt entspannt
es hat mich halt nicht sehr betroffen
obwohl es war am anfang da schon spürbar
aber es hat mich halt ich bin ich bin im
internet unterwegs das ist socialiste 10
at its best
und jetzt mache ich aber langsam so ein
frust in mir aufkommen also frust in dem
sinne
ich will wieder irgendwie ein bisschen
normales leben
und das geht nicht ich weiß wir müssen
halt noch diese zeit abwarten aber ich
fange an sachen zu vermissen die ich gar
nicht gedacht hätte dass ich sie brauche
meinem leben
na ja wir haben echt andere probleme als
irgendwelche jungen menschen die gerne
jetzt feiern gehen wollen würden
definitiv
sonst geht es mir gut um deine frage zu
beantworten bist du noch mit timo
zusammen das wird mein titel
ich glaube ich vergesse mal zu sagen
also ich mache ja vieles stories ich
habe die kamera ist gerade sieht relativ
gerade aus ich vergesse immer dass ich
quasi im internet eine geschichte
erzähle gerade auf instagram und ihr
mann musste für projekte in letzter zeit
oft weg über tage also war ich zu hause
habe ich gefühlt wie ein single war
richtig lonely da hat er richtig der
justin biebers song reingekriegt am soll
na ja auf jeden fall ja ich bin noch mit
ihm zusammen
sehr glücklich
aber er weiß halt lange nicht da also er
war mal wieder da muss wieder weg aber
es haben sich sehr viele leute in frage
viele leute wollten wissen
aber ich rede da offen drüber also ich
finde auch nicht schlimm wenn ihr mich
fragt gerade wenn er lange nicht zu
sehen ist
ich habe ihn euch ja vorgestellt meiner
internet familie und ich sehe es als
selbstverständlich dass euch das dann
interessiert ob wir zusammen sind oder
nicht ob alles in ordnung ist oder nicht
ich kann ja nicht steuern was euch
interessiert bzw
habe ich ja dafür gesorgt dass euch
meine beziehung interessiert wenn ich
sie öffentlich mache wie geht dein
partner mit deinen angststörungen um ist
er dir hilfe oder last also wir haben
auch gefragt ob ich noch meine angst
störung habe und da kann ich sagen da
habe ich nicht mehr ich habe sie
überwunden
ich habe ja schon öfter erzählt wie ich
meine anstellung losgeworden bin
einerseits durch hypnose therapie die
aber extrem teuer ist und ich sie
niemanden so einfach empfehlen würde
ich glaube da kostet eine sitzung 350
euro also das war schon eine gute
investition meines lebens aber
deine seele will frei sein bestes buch
für mich dieser mensch hat mir so meinen
kopf gewaschen auf eine positive art hat
er mich 180 grad gedreht also ich kann
sie nur mal kurz sagen ich habe am
wochenende gehabt da habe ich gesagt
jetzt auf in mir grund putz das mache
ich so alle paar wochen mal und dann
habe ich so dieses hörbuch gefunden weil
mir dass irgendjemand in die kommentare
geschrieben hat und noch etwas an
gemacht habe angefangen zu putzen alle
zehn minuten kamen mir wirklich die
tränen weil er so dazu gesagt kann man
es ja ich nehme dich bei der hand ist
alles nicht so schlimm
guck mal das ist so und so und du siehst
das falsch weil das ist so und so da
sehe ich meinen gottverdammten tisch wir
sind praktisch gesucht zum tisch der das
essen so müssen wärmer so zensieren
naja dann habe ich dieses hörbuch dieses
wochenende durch gehört und ich bin fit
ich bin danach zu timo gegangen herbst
richtig gespürt da war wie ein schalter
der unglück war ins kino gegangen hat
gesagt nur dass zu juno meine
panikattacken werk also ich hab keine
angst störung mehr nicht ich hab das
nicht mehr und timo war so ein bisschen
vorbelastet weil ich halt immer mal
wieder gekommen bin und gesagt haben die
hypnose voll gut geholfen ich glaube
jetzt ist es bald vorbei
das hat gut geholfen so deswegen war er
so da ist doch gut aber geglaubt das
nicht und irgendwann dann nach wochen
einer wirklich gesagt krass ich hätte
nicht geglaubt also ich ja ich dachte du
bist wieder einfach nur irgendwas neues
aber du bist wie ausgewechselt
das war geil das war echt geil
vor allem hat das hörbuch 9 eur 99
kostet also einmal otto will
guthaben besten investiertes geld
ok hoffentlich nicht so persönlich aber
wie gehst du mit dem thema angst um
ernst und da zitiere ich mein bruder
angst leben angst ist eigentlich dafür
da wofür das alles da um euch zu
beschützen
genauso könnte es aussehen wenn ihr
angst verspürt sagte danke körper dann
hörst du mich beschützen willst aber
hier ist nichts wenn es so leicht wäre
freut mir keine psychologen
ich bin grundsätzlich ein sehr
ängstlicher mensch aber
das schlimmste war angst vor dem tod und
angst vor krankheiten und angst vorm
sich verletzen
das muss man weg nehmen ich weiß jetzt
noch dass ich sterben werde
ich weiß es wird der tag kommen und ich
weiß tag musste ich mit 80 kommen
sondern er kann auch mit 35 kommen wird
mir dieser gesamthaft angst gemacht aber
heute
heute ist es wirklich für mich so ein
gedanke bei vanessa wäre ewig zeit macht
die dinge die ich glücklich machen will
mal deine base du musst nicht jedem
gefallen
du musst nicht die gras und die
krassesten sagen erreichen wenn du für
dich das erreicht was für dich reicht
also wenn du deine ziele erreicht dann
ist doch gut und wenn dein ziel ist
nicht länger als zwei stunden am tag zu
arbeiten sonst zu ziehen dann ist das
dein gott verdammtes ziel
man sollte aufhören sich fertig zu
machen irgendwelche leute die etwas
einreden wollen wie man zu sein hat die
zeiten sind vorbei
wir haben 2020
ein schönes jahr aber so sind also ab
jetzt beginnt die zeit der kein stehen
stärke
was zwischen persönlich aus 2020 ich
habe das gefühl euro fragen so ein
richtig schön die dadurch das was ich
sagen möchte 2020 ich ziehe aus 2020 ich
ziehe aus 2020 dass die welt wieder
zusammenkommen muss ich habe das gefühl
noch nie hat sich die gesellschaft
sondern so zwei lager aufgeteilt in
meiner in der zeit in der ich denke
bemerke
das wird sicherheit an also a coruna
gegner da sind doch boston das problem
bei corona gegner bzw
verschwörungstheoretiker das problem ist
dass sie nicht bei sich bleiben können
ihre eigene welt sie suchen unbedingt
den fehler und das problem im außen
irgendwer muss doch dafür schuld sein
dass sie sich so fühlen wie sie sich
fühlen und dadurch verrennen sie sich in
irgendwelche geschichten in irgendwelche
verschwörungen in irgendwelche keine
ahnung demos gegen masken weil die
masken und kinder sterben das ist alles
nicht bewiesen das ist alles so bei den
haaren herbeigezogene aussagen bleibt
man bei euch
habe gerade darüber nachgedacht wie
viele leute ich gerade auf findet habe
internet hat sich verändert hat es bei
soe lage sehen sind außerdem live update
gemacht und sich gesagt früher war das
internet so ein cosi place wo man halt
drin verschwinden konnte um vom echten
leben zu verschwinden
und heutzutage verschwindet man ins
echte leben damit man das internet mal
aus werden kann und social media
und das stimmt echt postino leidet ihr
seid echt interessieren
also wie gesagt im nebenraum da waren
meine storage und so nicht dabei weil er
einfach immer woanders war den ganzen
mist wissen
emily in paris gekauft und deswegen sind
jetzt nicht mehr affären für mich
sondern misst stressig für dienstboten
mistress das ist so geil wird irgendwie
sowas erhaben ist alles mist
wann hast du das letzte mal tränen
gelacht tränen gelacht aber elektrisch
wochenende hätte ich wenn mein bruder
war
wir haben so ein würfelspiel zur
depression gespielt und es war so
bescheiden lustig dabei weil mein bruder
hat noch eine beste freundin also ist
auch meine freundin nicht um einsame
freundin und ich finde es ist einfach
der lustigste mensch der welt bei ihrem
man sich wirklich tränen lachen
ach so ich kann ja auch ein bisschen an
zählen das wäre vielleicht auch mal ganz
interessant wo ich so die letzten wochen
die ganze zeit ab gehabt
das schreibt ach so ich kriege die
nachricht von ihm die heißt wie die
beste freundin die uns immer so zum
lachen bringt und ich lasse sie schreibt
aber es sich vorgestellt hat hallo ich
bin blieb von bega thema
wie das so lief letzten wochen bei mir
zweithöchsten so gemacht vanessa wo
warst du ich war hin und hergerissen
musste immer wieder nachwuchs also ins
alte land muss sich fahren und habe
meine mal ins krankenhaus gekommen ist
sagt natürlich nicht was mit ihr war und
so sie war sechs wochen da und von der
sieben war ganz schön lange zeit
naja und die spd hat mein bruder mein
vater urlaub und damit nicht gekommen
arbeit geholfen das haus aufzuräumen
bis in ordnung zu machen und so für mein
bruder da zu sein und dann wohl aber
relativ schnell klar dass meine mutter
halt zu krank ist und das alles zu lange
dauert und mein vater wieder zu arbeiten
muss und keine david o das war dann halt
erstmal zum kleiner act ein bisschen
seien eltern so ein bisschen wagen
gefahren ist aber wir haben einfach die
lebensretterin bekommen eine so nette
tolle pflegerin ist gekommen
die wohl die zwei metern und dann da sie
bei meinen eltern wohnt muss sich
natürlich auch ein zimmer für sie
vorbereitet
mein dachboden also mein altes zimmer
der dachboden maus einfach 37 jahre lang
keiner herum gelaufen wäre und das war
auch so wie im jahre lang ist kein
herumgelaufen außer meine nichte die hat
darf uns mal geschlafen aber es war ein
großes chaos und es war viel
kinderspielzeuge alte kiste nirgendwo
unheil das war eine rumpelkammer
naja und dann das beste war dann haben
meine mutter angerufen ich habe das
gesagt wenn mama werden dach wohnen für
sie machen wer stück
sein vater ist steht daneben und ich sag
weil ich die farbe im zimmer gehasst hat
das war so ein hässliches gelb und dann
hat sie noch so viele monate im modus
und moderne so van gogh so ein bisschen
wahnsinnig dann hat sie angefangen
reichs in die farbe zu mischen und auf
die wende zu klatschen um so einen
raufaser look zu kriegen das war nicht
billigere variante fürs verspachteln und
dann heute sicher diesen rauf hasel
ukraine am ende hast du einfach nur
diesen preis der an der wand klebt den
er auch über jahre den jungen ab und zu
abgeholt habe oder meine freundin
deswegen habe ich am telefon gesagt
meine mutter hasst preis als sie dann
ein video zu sehen hat terrakotta halle
habe ich gesagt ja und ich würde gerne
weiß streiten
mein vater steht daneben und chris schon
so meine mutter sagt ja weiß vielleicht
lieber so eierschale nicht so ok hab gar
nicht gedacht dass also also mein hirn
konnte gar nicht so schlecht dann ebenso
denkbar es war und in dem moment dachte
ich mir so niemann wenn monats grad
erlaubt ich darf in diesem haus etwas
weiß streichen ich so alles klar
mit blick auf mein vater grenze heber
von lustigen weiß streichen
papa
du denkst ich haben oder fahrrad ich
habe dich verarscht wir streichen weiß
ja nie weiß gestrichen das war toll
dann habe ich aus dem ganzen haus habe
irgendwelche dekoartikel genau mögliche
körper irgendwelche decken habe so reeh
die tine wittler darum gespielt und es
ist wirklich so schön geworden
da habe ich ein gutes gefühl da hab ich
gedacht ja da kann sie drin leben das
ist nicht so hier ist dein bett und
irgendwie ein schrank sondern es war so
ein richtiges kommt man das ist dein
zimmer aber sie ist dieses goldstück
gelernt meine eltern haben jetzt einfach
wie so ein liebes mädchen das war das
war aus strange saison war er dann zu
besuchen dann wenn wir am
frühstückstisch oder mittagstisch und
irgendwann steht sie auch wenig an die
tische abzuräumen und das ist halt ich
finde ich in ordnung halte wie ist er
quasi bezahlt dort deswegen habe ich
dann am nächsten tag kritischen blick
eröffnen würde schnell aufgesprungen
also teller abgesagt herr nähe wartete
doch mal das ist mein job und ich
zunehme
sorry
die sind mit grünkohl und spinat
manchmal gar nicht so gut
naja jetzt ist meine mutter wieder zu
hause ihr geht so lala
die wunden und so müssen noch heilen und
blau weil ihr euch dem leser ein
herauszuholen ja oh mein gott ich will
so gerne einen hund haben vor sich
katzen und eigentlich doch die auch mal
dass ich ein mensch bin ich glaube ich
bin ein hundemensch welche zu hause war
wenn ich mal mit meinem hund gegangen
habe mich heute auch in den hund
gekümmert weil das ganze mein ganzes
familienhaushalt ist zusammengebrochen
da es meine mutter weg war mein vater
musste irgendwie urlaub nehme arbeiten
gehen sondern habe ich mich halt
unbekümmert erde wird sich so spaß daran
mit diesem holz zu gehen ihn zu füttern
ihn zu kennen ihn zu pflegen ist gerade
schon roboter bauen und es tut mir so
leid super aber ich werde mir keinen
holen
das wäre unverantwortlich
ja es wird von frauen verbessern
wir sind noch so viel unterwegs dafür
und wir haben nicht so direkt zum
beispiel haben auch keine direkten
nachbarn die mal einspringen könnten
es war halt immer aneckt
wie bleibst du bei diesem ganzen mist
mit dem locker und so gut drauf
vielleicht sagen sie mir nicht schwer
behaltet eure gute laune leute
also also wie die dinge sind so ist kann
eine perspektivische frage sein
man kann sich ja auch ziemlich schön und
die pläne zielen lockt dann hat auch
jemand gefragt wie sie trainiert bin
noch beim zum beispiel sind wollen harry
über eine harry potter marathon machen
einen herr der ringe marathon aber nicht
nur ein marathon sondern wir kochen auch
was dazu machen vielleicht irgendwelche
süßigkeiten halt irgendwie aktionen wie
willst du verfehlen
irgendwie was essen zu gehen sich mit
freunden zu treffen
ja leute die situation sehr oft aber man
muss wirklich das beste draus machen
es gibt also sagen wir mal ein paar
monate
was hatte ich jetzt zum beispiel nach
dem letzten loch bahnhof ich habe mich
ein bisschen geärgert dass ich nicht
mehr meine pace gechillt ab wenn man es
kann natürlich reden wir hier nicht von
den systemrelevanten berufen die sich
aus also die sich vieles nicht leisten
können auch kein schild kein ding
bei denen geht das einfach ganz normal
weiter vielleicht sogar noch
anstrengender als vorher aber für die
die in dieser glücklichen situation sind
dass ein bisschen gerade alles runter
gefahren wird nimmt der salz geschenk
wenn ihr das als bestrafung nehmt
vielleicht ärgert ihr euch noch ein paar
wochen und sagt dann da war es wieder
das ist alles wieder so stressig da im
lockdown da habe ich nur in meiner
jogginghose gechillt
es ist doch mal ganz gut die welt dreht
sich weiter und die dreht sich manchmal
aber ein bisschen zu schnell habe ich
das gefühl
und wenn man schon mal so ein monat
bekommt wo man halt nicht viel machen
kann außer bitte vitamin d nehmen
und geh bitte spazieren
sucht euch einen grund um rauszugehen
ihr müsst ihr nicht in eine straße gehen
die irgendwie voll beladen ist sondern
einfach rausgehen frische luft schnappen
nicht in der bude rocken machst du da
block max dass ein blog marx ja ich
mache wieder blog mesz nach dem ersten
dezember geht's los
ich freue mich so sehr auf dieses mal
zieht das bis zum 24
durch das könnt ihr euch sicher sein wie
wäre dein leben ohne youtube geworden
da sind wir ganz schön liebe frage wie
mache ich mal fünf schnelle fragen mit
tommy lee wir machen einfach schnell ich
schaffte ein fahrer nicht mehr da ich
erst später auf obwohl sie gar nicht so
erhitzen spende ist du manchmal blut nie
habe ich noch nie gemacht würde ich aber
gerne mal wie geht es dir mit den augen
sehr gut meine augen sind gut ich habe
augentropfen die helfen dagegen und
seite keine kohle mehr und trinke oder
ihr allgemein sehr auf meine ernährung
achte frische sachen es habe ich keine
lichtempfindlichkeit werden also so viel
zu hause aktivitäten für den lotter
umgeplant harry potter marathon malen
herr der ringe marathon buch lesen essen
ausschlafen viel tee trinkt im bett
kuscheln lichter anmachen und mit timo
kuscheln funk hast du und wie willst du
mit dem nächsten lockt ordnung gehen ich
werde ihnen den lockdown annehmen werde
sagen komm lockdown und kann man mal
darüber sprechen das ist ja kennt
software lockdown oder also mann wird
gebeten zu hause zu bleiben
man darf mich irgendwie über zwei
haushalte zehn personen und so was
draußen sein
alle geschäfte sind zu allen sport
aktivitäten sind so außer die schule
also wir dürfen noch arbeiten gehen und
also sind die schule aber
so ein lock down oder ach so hätte es ja
wohl nicht letzte jahr letzte mal war ja
sogar spielplätze und so zu es ist
dieses mal auch wieder so ist ihm oder
im future husband wirst du thema
heiraten kannst du sie vorstellt timo zu
heiraten willst du mal heiraten
dass das uci was interessiert ja ich
möchte heiraten also zur zeit kann es ja
nur timo werden wenn sich noch was
ändert aber ich warte hier noch auf den
antrag
ich wüsste gar nicht immer so eine frage
wenn man sich schon länger zusammen ist
dann denkt man so wenn er mich jetzt
fragen würde würde ich ja sagen und ich
kann das nicht ganz mit 100 prozent
beantworten ich finde also wenn man dann
in der situation ist und es noch mal was
anderes nummer eins sofort das wenn man
in der situation ist dass man plötzlich
denkt nein nein ich irgendwie wenn man
vorher nicht drüber nachdenkt aber ja
mal gucken was die zukunft sagt ja was
hilft gegen panikattacken gegen
panikattacken heute hilft eine sache ich
habe da vorne am anfang schon darüber
gesprochen aber er hat nicht aufgrund zu
arbeiten akzeptiert das nicht das ist so
als ob ihr keine ahnung mit krankheit
also panikattacken sinn der krankheit
ich finde zu keinem zeitpunkt seiner
panikattacken zeit wenn man es hat darf
man das akzeptieren nun ja ich bin jetzt
halt ein mensch mit panikattacken
das ist der falsche weg und ja ich weiß
therapeuten zu finden die ein helfen
können das dauert ewig und kriegt man
einen termin in sechs monaten aber dann
hast du schon mal einen termin gemacht
und es gibt viele möglichkeiten
gruppentherapie
hypnose bücher einfach bücher die einem
bisschen helfen geistlich sich weiter zu
entwickeln und vielleicht hilft es dann
einen auch die panikattacken loszuwerden
meine therapeutin war so begeistert von
mir weil ich zu ihr gekommen bin und
gesagt habe ich habe seit sechs monaten
panikattacken und ich will jetzt
unbedingt was dagegen machen und sehe
mich angeschaut sechs monate manche
leute kommen hier rein und haben es 11
jahre sehen wir was machen wir dann die
elf jahre
die haben es einfach und akzeptieren
einfach dass wir so leben müssen und das
ist der falsche weg weil wir sind ja
mittlerweile schon so weit dass wir
sagen geistliche krankheiten sind
krankheiten als ob die jetzt den arm
bricht oder irgendwas im kopf fast wie
panikattacken und würdest du jetzt auch
nicht den arm brechen und sagen ich muss
jetzt meinen arm schonen
ich muss so leben hier ist vieles grünen
drauf ich muss jetzt so leben dass
nichts meinen arm
ich muss jetzt so leben dass nichts mein
arm anstößt weil ich habe einen
gebrochenen arm
nein du gehst zuerst nur gis menschen
die helfen können diesen arm wieder zu
reparieren und dann kümmerst du dich
darum und das machen viele leute mit
geist mit psychischen sache nicht sagt
geistlichen wie zu löschen
eine depressive phase zusammen ist okay
und man darf also man darf auch nicht
vergessen und man kann auch eine
depressive phase haben
ich finde immer viele leute ist zeigen
sehr auf den finger mit auf ein wenn man
sagt ich fühle mich in letzter zeit
depressiv du weißt ja gar nicht was
depressionen windbeutel kurstreiber
berührt ja es sind auch keiner weg nur
weil man sagt ich habe mich in den
letzten zeit degressiv gefühl kann man
haben dafür braucht man keine diagnose
irgendwie ein arzt der einem sagt ins
wenn du dich depressiv
das sind ist es so und man kann das so
was alles mal haben aber wenn etwas
nicht mehr weggeht
wenn eine angststörung also wenn eine
panikattacke kam und an die nächste und
dann bei der dritten und du merkst du
fängst an deinen alltag einzuschränken
und du sagst ich nehme jetzt doch nicht
die bahn weil in der bahn habe ich eine
panikattacke gehen dieses restaurant
kann ich nicht gehen weil ich meine
panikattacken bekommen ich gehe keine
ahnung nicht mehr mit freunden lassen
das machen weil manchmal kriegt eine
panikattacke
das ist kein zustand in dem man leben
sollte und ich muss ehrlich sagen so
schnell wie ich in diese panikattacken
reingerutscht bin
das hat mich nicht angekündigt von wegen
wenn du dich jetzt noch so überlastet
ist wenn du nicht auf mich hörst wenn du
in dieser stresssituation bleibst
kriegst du in zwei wochen eine
panikattacke
es kann natürlich super schleichend und
dann war es plötzlich da und das hat
mich so überrannt ich habe mich so
hilflos gefühlt aber ich habe zwei tage
gebraucht und haben angefangen zu gucken
was ich dagegen tun kann
ich habe endlose endlos viele bücher
gehört zu therapeuten akupunktur ich
habe einfach alles gemacht weil ich es
aber auch nicht akzeptieren wollte und
das ist auch in ordnung akzeptieren
niemals irgendwelche sachen die du
wieder ändern kannst bei panikattacken
können wieder gehen
und du musst keine zehn jahre damit
verbringen dich so einzuschränken und
sich schlecht zu fühlen jetzt komme ich
nicht mehr aus dieser scheiße raus wie
war deine führerschein
ich bin zweimal durchgefallen zweimal in
der schriftlichen und zweimal in der
praktischen machst du noch sport nein
ich wünschte bist du momentan zufrieden
mit einem dreh zimmer überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht ich weiß über 7 ändern
soll
es ist furchtbar ich bin heute morgen so
früh aufgestanden weil ich so angst
hatte dass ich dieses video nicht
pünktlich schaffen denn es geht heute
online
wenn ihr im bisher überhaupt geschaut
hat das macht das und mich freuen wenn
du bis hierhin geschafft habt wenn ihr
bis hierhin geschaut habt auch wenn ihr
keinen kommentarschreiber seit ich muss
das hier mal ein bisschen mit diesen wie
heißt das engagement eine community
meine zuschauer müssen bisschen mehr
engagement das markiert sagt youtube ist
superklasse deswegen wenn ihr bis
hierhin geschaut habe schreibt mir eine
vierzeilige damit sich die leute wundern
den nun die kommentare reingehen und sie
lesen wollen
warum der gedichte steht also viel
zahlen das muss ich ein
und dann
würde ich sagen bis zum nächsten mal ein
echtes gefallen hat und ihr unbedingt
noch andere sachen wissen wollt dann
schreibt sie mir sehr gerne in die
kommentare
also außer dem gedicht vielleicht mache
ich das wieder öfter also ich wollte
gerade sagen wenn es gut ankommt aber
eigentlich sollte es ja bei mir gut
ankommt ich möchte sie also ich muss es
machen wollen
aber das ist das problem mit einem auf
dieser welt noch nicht genug klicks
macht warum gott ist überschaubar wir
schauen wir wie es ankommt ich schau mal
wie es mir auch am ende gefällt und dann
sehen wir das nächste mal wieder jetzt
denkt dran
kaufland die ecken wo reduzierte nah am
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum stehende
produkte sind und die etwas anderen auch
mal mitnehmen die müssen hässlicheren
und ihr findet links noch in der video
beschreibung da findet ihr zum beispiel
rezepte vom kaufland und noch mal die
etwas anderen ist an eure vanessa